[Música]
esta historia arranca hace 18 años en mi
casa uno de los roles de la mujer el de
mi mamá era servirle a tiempo la comida
mi papá siempre me pregunte porque no
era al revés y es que en colombia según
la encuesta del dane de uso del tiempo
nosotras las mujeres hoy en día aún
gastamos el doble de tiempo que los
hombres en las actividades del hogar
entonces en ese momento al entender por
qué se gastaba el doble de tiempo
siempre cualquier gesto de desigualdad
me generó una inconformidad porque estoy
segura que nosotras las mujeres tenemos
un compromiso y tenemos un reto de
proteger y protagonizar aún mayor nos
falta un recorrido pero hemos mejorado y
sobre todo porque nuestra
responsabilidad actuar vivir pero sobre
todo ocupar esos espacios en los que nos
sentimos capaces
con el tiempo pues he reflexionado un
poco sobre el papel de la mujer y el
liderazgo de nosotras en la sociedad y
resulta que antes las mujeres lucharon
para ponerse pantalones en ese momento
el pantalón significaba ese símbolo de
igualdad por el poder y por la libertad
resulta que aunque las mujeres avanzaron
hacía poder ponerse los pantalones o
hacia ese digamos lo que querían lograr
con esa igualdad los hombres nunca
aceptaron que las mujeres se pudieran
vestir igual que ellos y así fue cuando
en 1800 en parís una una ordenanza le
dijo a las mujeres les prohibió que no
se podían vestir o que no podían usar un
atuendo igual que al de los hombres
imagínense la rebelión que eso pudo
haber ocasionado imagínense que eso
pasara hoy en día pero gracias a esa
rebelión hoy las mujeres podemos escoger
si ponernos pantalón o ponernos falda
pero yo le estoy hablando del atuendo
como tal les estoy hablando lo que
significó en ese momento
poder tener esa decisión de poder elegir
y es ahí cuando les digo que hoy me
pongo la falda y me la pongo bien puesta
porque para mí ya no significa represión
para mí lo que significa hoy es al
contrario esa libertad y ese símbolo de
igualdad que estas mujeres lucharon
les quiero contar que hoy me estoy
poniendo también está falta porque estoy
emprendiendo un nuevo reto y es el reto
hacer política y es que si bien yo estoy
convencida además no tengo miedo de
tener nada toda mi vida he hecho retos
con los hombres que qué espacio que
diferente puede hacer esto y es que hoy
tenemos nosotras como mujeres un rol
distinto es decir yo soy casado tengo 31
años y también tengo presión social como
muchas de ustedes que quieren que cuando
los hijos aquí están algunas de mis tías
que quieren que en file muy rápidamente
y apoyemos la línea de nietos y
bisnietos pero pues claro además de eso
que muchas de las personas dicen como
para que uno me va a meter a hacer
política de más política de más en un
mundo de hombres y claro eso en algún
momento era impensable que nosotros
pudiéramos hacer política o estar en un
rol donde se tomarán las decisiones en
un contexto donde uno conociera de
primera mano qué era lo que estaba
pasando por ejemplo en la ciudad pero
además de eso
aún más inconcebible que nosotras las
mujeres pudiéramos ser nuestras
pudiéramos tener jefaturas de cabeza de
familia y les cuento que hoy en colombia
el 32% la tercera parte de los hogares
es liderado por una mujer por cualquiera
que sea la razón hoy creamos los niños
hoy trabajamos hoy estudiamos y hacemos
deporte nos vamos de compras y eso sí es
tener la falda bien puesta
pero les quiero contar por qué hago
política y es que me gusta hago política
porque me gusta de estar el lado donde
se toman las decisiones del lado donde
uno puede decidir dónde está el poder y
por qué el poder el poder para tomar
decisiones el poder para cambiar las
cosas que creemos que no están bien el
poder sobre todo para generar
oportunidades pero les digo algo yo no
hago política por ser mujer yo hago
política porque me gustan los retos y me
gusta el reto dignificar la política y
el reto dignifica la política no es de
hombres ni es de mujeres
el reto dignificar la política es el
reto de los mejores hay que los mejores
tienen que llegar a cada uno de los
espacios donde se toman las decisiones
por eso mujeres es en esos espacios
donde nosotros tenemos que hacer
partícipes donde tenemos que hacer parte
de la sociedad donde tenemos que poner
también como mujeres este derecho que ya
todos adquirimos y es que les cuento
como dice michelle bachelet y es que
cuando una mujer hace política ella
cambia pero cuando nosotras hacemos
política cuando
mujeres hacemos políticas la política
cambia y hoy el lazo estoy invitando no
que todas salgamos a hacer campaña ni a
ser candidatas sino que sí tenemos que
tener responsabilidad con esos derechos
nuestra responsabilidad de hacer parte
de lo público de donde vivimos de la
toma de decisiones y les digo algo si en
ese camino por dignificar la política
nunca nos pueden faltar las agallas para
combatir la corrupción y si eso llega a
pasar les cuento que mueve amarrar la
falda bien duro y voy a emprender una
nueva lucha lucha para que todas
nosotras como mujeres nunca perdamos los
sueños porque este es el único miedo que
nosotras podemos perder y es el único
miedo que nosotras podemos tener y es el
miedo a perder nuestros sueños nuestra
transformación así que mujeres nosotras
tenemos nuestro propio estilo
tenemos nuestra propia fuerza nosotros
no necesitamos los pantalones para tener
voz nosotras
tenemos la falda bien puesta y les digo
algo donde lo hagan como lo harán con
quien lo hagan todas ustedes mujeres con
la falda bien puesta de ratas
empoderadas y capaces
[Aplausos]